el pulmón verde de gabón y hogar de
miles de especies
la selva tropical de la Cuenca del Congo
es una de las mayores del mundo solo
superada por el Amazonas
está repartida en seis países entre
ellos acabón casi el 90% del cual está
cubierto de bosques que absorben el
equivalente a un tercio de las emisiones
anuales de Francia uno de los países con
más bosques del mundo solo por detrás de
surinami micronesia
tiene una economía negativa en carbono
saturnina se despierta en medio del
Bosque en lo alto de una Atalaya desde
la que puede observar a los animales
salvajes
estamos intentando ver si hay algún
animal para mirar esta mañana sí tenemos
dos elefantes no se trata de elefantes
cualquiera sino de elefantes africanos
de bosque una especie poco común que ha
sido víctima de la caza furtiva y la
deforestación en los últimos años hasta
el 70% de estos elefantes que aún viven
en libertad están aquí en gabón también
se ha convertido en un santuario para
docenas de otras especies amenazadas
como estos gorilas realmente es un
paraíso para estos animales porque aquí
tienen todo lo que necesitan tienen
hierba sales minerales agua potable
tras sus observaciones matinales
saturning regresa al suelo del Bosque en
la lista de tareas de hoy una excursión
por el bosque ibindo
uno de los 13 parques nacionales de
gabón
en esta zona protegida Nadie puede
deambular solo debe ir escoltado por
guardas a forestales patrullan a
centenares vigilando tanto a los
animales como a Los visitantes
aquí hay especies muy amenazadas
elefantes Búfalos y gorilas
todos corren un gran peligro por culpa
de los cazadores furtivos debemos
proteger este parque
en Las dos últimas décadas el gobierno
de gabón ha protegido más de dos
millones de hectáreas de bosque
libreville se ha comprometido a seguir
siendo un pozo de carbono hasta 2050 y
aún más en primera línea de esta lucha
se encuentra este centro de
investigación sobre biodiversidad
longitud del tallo
63 centímetros
de reforestación aquí en el parque
aquí están cultivando que va 5 una de
las especies de árboles víctimas del
tráfico de madera el bosque es nuestra
vida los árboles desempeñan un papel
importante en el equilibrio global
debemos centrarnos en la reforestación
es nuestra misión dentro de unos cientos
de años los arbolitos que crezcan en el
centro serán tan altos como este gran
árbol
en total los bosques de la Cuenca del
Congo absorben cada año alrededor del 4%
de nuestro co2
ese paisaje natural único atrae a
visitantes de todo el mundo
estos turistas estadounidenses pasan un
mes entero en los bosques de gabón lejos
de la vida urbana y de las comodidades
habituales
tenemos una fuga por aquí entra un poco
de agua es divertido eres valiente
Supongo eso es lo que dice mis hijos
después de tres horas en Canoa los
turistas llegan a la Joya de la corona
del parque de ibindo
esto rápidos han sido reconocidos
recientemente como patrimonio Mundial de
la UNESCO
los ecoturistas son una parte importante
del plan de gabón para reforzar su
economía de carbono negativo
[Música]